just former deputy assistant to the
president Sebastian Gorka is with us
it's interesting every time what do we
learn that the the Communist mayor of
New York gave up the surveillance
program we've since that I believe three
attacks then of course we go back to the
issue of immigration then we go back to
the the president having to fight in the
court so we can vet people that come
from countries that do not share our
values and it keeps coming up every
attack and yet the left still supports
these policies it's hard to understand
dr. korkor it truly is as Sean this
should have surprised nobody the
president understands that the
immigration system that he inherited is
utterly completely bankrupt the last New
York attacker managed to sponsor more
than twenty people on a chain migration
into the United States this jihadist was
also a person who came in through chain
migration I just arrived yesterday back
from Australia Australia for example has
a completely merit-based immigration
system and completely strict adherence
to the question of why are you coming to
this country do you contribute to this
country and are you a threat why can't
America have a system like Australia's
is a question to answer because if
people are caught and entering Australia
illegally let's say they're in a boat
well Australia is very compassionate
they will give them enough food and
water and supplies so they can get back
to their destination their original
destination somebody is sick they won't
even take them into the country they'll
take him to a separate island and take
care of them but you're right if we
opened our borders completely we could
pick and choose everybody would want to
come here the best the brightest
contributors that would make society
better that don't have values that
contradict our values why is that so
complicated how does that get so
politicized well look the fact is the
left has tried to sell a bill of goods
in where they say everybody has the
right to come to America it's insanity
if that's the case the word America
ceases to have any meaning remember what
Hillary did Sean she gave a private
speech that we now
have the transcript of where she said
there should be no borders in the
Western Hemisphere from Canada all the
way down no borders if that were the
case if she'd have won the America would
cease to exist as a concept and we'd be
having not just one attack every few
weeks or every few months it would be
like Europe with attacks occurring every
couple of days let me shift gears let me
go to the issue of all of these fake
news reports that I laid out a my
opening monologue tonight
they're everywhere it's almost on a
daily basis we have known a long time
that real journalism is dead in the
country I said that no7 and no.8
but the agenda of the media now they
they are actively trying to undermine
and unseat and contributing to unseat a
duly elected president forces like we've
never seen a line together how should
the president deal with it we have a
deadly combination Sean your monologue
is spot on the left has created a web I
hate conspiracy theories but if you look
at what the media is doing if you look
at how things like the FBI have become
politicized nobody's getting in trouble
in the FBI for having Republican views
what's happening there Democrats they
they have been in contravention of the
Hatch Act they've given Hillary he'd
glove treatment for things that would
have sent you or I to prison how do we
respond leadership and we have to drain
the swamp the president has to drive the
people with political agendas out of
government because if you're a
bureaucrat your politics should be a
private affair they shouldn't affect
policy and the media look I hope it's
going to be market forces you are
crushing it on cable news you're number
one as long as you know the market
forces dictate things like CNN will
become irrelevant sooner or later I
think somebody pointed out that the
cartoon network was rated higher I don't
know if that's still true but that was
true at the time what are you doing a
case of a Muller investigation where we
now know that is Clinton lovers Trump
haters people that in the past have have
not passed on exculpatory information to
defendants somebody that has made up
laws
and it's a whole cadre of people now
that all have one agenda what is the
answer to in in your mind because I
don't see an easy answer to untangle the
mess of politics now that is corrupted
that special counsel well let me remind
your audience and let me remind that the
DNC the chief law enforcement officer of
the United States according to the US
Constitution is not the director of the
FBI nor it is nor is it the Attorney
General the chief law enforcement
officer is the president and right now
that's Donald J Trump he could fire
Mahler legally tomorrow if he so wished
but he would have to be backed up by the
Republican Party we need to see
leadership from Capitol Hill that
understand that sessions do that I think
Jeff's trust sessions is in a very
difficult place right now with his very
very ill-advised
decision to recuse himself from the
Russia investigation he can reassert he
can reassert his power as the Attorney
General but we also have to see a
broader support from from Congress for
the president his agenda and what
November the 8th really means to America
all right Sebastian Gorka good to have
you back thank you